put them together please for aaron
rodgers
[Applause]
[Music]
you take that all day long right there
man
yeah
that's a good one there
he's a good spin off the ridge too you
don't want to be a great shot brother oh
man this is aaron put me down for a
three trev okay
i got you
to win the
first shot
[Music]
nicely done nicely done
good putt get up there
[Applause]
this guy's pretty good at
that's golf happens when you don't go to
otas you just
get up there
get up there and go
nice pot that's good
jake i mean i ain't not that good but i
know what i'm supposed to do oh
this this could be good if it stays in
the air oh there you go oh nice bearing
oh my gosh look at this
nice shot come on
baby
[Music]
oh well done that's all right
that's a great answer by aaron rodgers
way to avoid the question yeah by
processing donations
somebody out there is a bad putter
look at that oh wow
i was dead spot on again yeah but you
didn't ask ernie's
that was clutch sitting next to you all
day it sounds like you don't ever hit a
bunker oh here we go guys here we go
we got a chance here cutting
big hop come
on nice shot aaron
nice shot that's a beauty right there
aaron got the blue roof down there hey
chuck if he hits it uh-oh neither of us
have any idea
these guys been flaring that ball right
all day they had not hit a hook oh
that's a nice ball
what a shot wow what a shot my goodness
right there it's narrow down here too
right and short of the green and that's
a beauty
[Applause]
and he can close the door here on number
12.
oh my god and he jumped why
yes sir
oh my gosh
wow
that's awesome i think about three feet
from the cup he knew that was going
straight down
you